Marko's is with us in our Marco's is
with us in Dallas hi Marcos how are you
hey you Dave how are you doing better
not deserve how can I help
thank you so much and thank you so much
for changing my life and perceptions
money for the better I really appreciate
all that info you uh you get out well
thank you how can I help
yeah well I'm on baby step three I have
been working for about for about ten
years a major bank I'm looking to change
my career to my passion which is
personal training and so it's kind of a
scary time and so I'm trying to see if
you have any insight to what I could do
to make this a smooth transition get
your personal training in come up close
to your bank income and then the
transition becomes a no-brainer right
right the jump the leap is the one is
what scares you and that's where people
break their leg is in the leap so what
do you make now at the bank
it's about forty three thousand good and
what is your personal training income
currently running annually well I was
training out a small gym for a while and
then I realized that they may think also
of your profits so I wanted to do it on
my own so I actually don't have any
clients yet but my tenure job told me
that as of May I will no longer have a
position so basically as of May of next
year one have a position with them with
that Bank and so then I will be I have a
choice of by getting any severance at
that point I think so well thinking is
from here till May to save up as much as
I can kind of finalize my my fully
funded emergency fund and then from
there I'll have a separate which will be
approximately about fifteen to eighteen
thousand to go with and kind of help me
again are you married
I not okay yeah I would definitely pile
up every dime squeeze every dime out I
can do to get ready for May and then the
other thing you need to do is you need
64 clients you need to be working all
the time as soon as you leave the bank
you're gonna be running out the
backdoor in your shorts and shoes ready
to go work somebody out okay you got you
you need to have in-home clients wealthy
people that have their own gyms you need
to have people that want to do outside
workouts and you locate parks with
stairs or whatever it is whatever your
methodology is that you use that your
differentiator where you can get to
people and you don't need a gym plus you
need to be thinking about how you're
going to get a deal with a gym long-term
because you don't want to build one
initially right and so we need to be
looking for a deal with the gym looking
for in-home looking for outside stuff
good news is you're in Dallas so that's
going to work fairly quickly in early
next year you the weather will break in
the South quicker and you can get
outside if you need to but what you
needs a bunch of clients because
basically what could happen is is the
severance pay could be your signing
bonus to your new life let's pretend you
made you had 25 or you that you had
$50,000 a year worth of clients by May
okay then when they give you that
severance check it all goes in the bank
doesn't it right and this is a oh you've
retired me I didn't even notice
that's one more question if you don't
mind as far as like investments because
I do have investments that I've had as
my fall on K do the bank and I mean it's
always been put into a 7,500
I'm also given a pension that will be
able to roll over as well but I've never
done it before this will eat my first
time so I don't know what your best
practices are a minute okay I would do a
direct transfer rollover of everything
that you're vested in your 401 K and if
you invested in your pension into just
traditional IRA there'll be no taxes on
that at all that's when you leave the
bank and I invest and I recommend people
invest in mutual funds with long track
records in four categories evenly a
fourth in each growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international and
that's what I would do there now Marcus
I really
you hear that first part of what we
talked about I'm not exaggerating I want
you to run like your hair is on fire
pretend like you're working with your
one of your clients and you're the
client only instead of weight loss and
heart rate change and whatever other
maître metric or measure you want to use
to measure physical health we're
measuring your business health by
whether you have $50,000 worth of
clients a year what do you what do you
what do you charge a client what would
you try a client if I came to you right
now um I'd be about either 40 or 50
dollars per hour just depending on how
many times you see me for weeks
okay all right and so if we said $50,000
it's a thousand hours right by $50 okay
which is 80 hours a week okay no that's
80 hours a month I'm sorry 20 hours a
week and so 21 hours a week Saul you got
to be working to break even on your bank
job it's really doable but you got to
believe it and you got to get out there
and market yourself and you got to you
got to work at getting clients as hard
as you want them to work at losing
weight yeah I mean it's because I have
I'm saving up money so I can have an
opportunity to see oh before I yeah yeah
no no no missing the point I don't want
you to use any of the saved money you're
not gonna need any saved money if you do
what I just told you to do you're gonna
be making as much if you have $50,000
worth of clients if you have 21 hours a
week booked at 50 dollars you are making
as much as you make at the bank and I
want 21 hours a week booked before May
gets here
on average I want you to build that many
customers however many customers that
write that it turns out to be okay and
then you won't need to touch your
savings every time you tell me you want
to touch your savings you're telling me
you don't believe this business is going
to succeed and you're not gonna do the
work before you get laid off and made to
make sure it succeeds and this is the
coach kicking you in the butt and
telling you to do the pushup
get it done get it done you can do this